so I've been struggling with an idea
recently that I was thinking maybe you'd
be able to help me out with basically in
a recent interview you talked about how
myth is meant to reconcile inherent
contradictions in reality right but
I'm sort of stuck between two
mythological or
psychoanalytic ideas that I think are
both really important but they seem to
have a inherent contradiction within
them that I've been trying to figure out
so on one hand you have this idea that
there's times in your life where you
have to identify things in yourself that
are insufficient or there's a problem
somehow that you have to kind of have a
controlled burn or like a phoenix-like
transformation where you discard part of
yourself that doesn't fit or is not
working but then on the other hand you
have talked about this this Union idea
where as you become
really when you get older you mature by
reincorporating things about yourself
that you lost when you were younger or
that you know you're trying to integrate
Your Shadow or you're trying to find
parts of your personality that
that maybe you've been rejecting and try
and figure out how to bring them into
into the fold or into the hole so he's
got this quote that I really like which
is I'd rather be whole than good right
right so so on one hand you may identify
something as a problem and you want to
get rid of it or burn it off but then on
the other hand it seems like the the
path to
being stronger is to figure out how to
put everything together
so there's a there's a one of the things
Jung wrote about in his works on Alchemy
was an explanation of the Prime
alchemical dictum which was Solvay
coagula which meant dissolve and
integrate
right so so imagine this imagine that
imagine you had a fairly hostile father
who was not very well controlled in his
aggression
decent person other than that but let's
say that and so your reaction is I'm
never going to be aggressive
and so you've built a like a moral
structure that's part of your
personality
and there's possibility floating around
outside of that that you you've denied
an ethical
denied any ethical
what would you say you've stripped the
idea of aggression of any ethical
utility whatsoever
okay so what happens this Burns off and
then that comes back up now you still
have to integrate it so It's associated
in some sense with Nietzsche's ideas
morality as cowardice because one of
Nietzsche's most trenchant critiques of
traditional morality let's say is that
most of what passes for Morality isn't
morality it's just cowardice it's not
that I'm a good person and I don't hurt
you it's that I'm afraid to hurt you and
because I don't want to admit that I'm
afraid to hurt you then I say I'm moral
because then I can mask my Essential
fear and cowardice in a guise of
morality and that happens far more often
than you would think because harmless
and moral are by no means the same thing
so some of what you're burning off you
can sit and this is where Freud was such
a genius I think is because he
concentrated on aggression and sexuality
which are perhaps the two most difficult
parts of a personality to integrate said
that
um
the the
hyper-simplified morality stops you from
tapping into deeper recesses of your
psyche and it's partly because they're
Primal forces it's not surprising that
you don't want to have anything to do
with them that you stay away from
situations where they might make
themselves manifest but the problem is
by denying the worst in yourself in that
manner suppressing it you preclude the
possibility of the best because no one
can be a good person without integrating
their capacity for aggression
because without that capacity of for
aggression you cannot say no
because no means if you really say it no
means there isn't anything that you can
do to me that will make me change my
mind or or conversely it means I will
play for higher Stakes than you will
and
unless you've got your aggression
integrated there isn't a chance you can
say that and if you did no one would
take you seriously because they'd know
it was just a show
so one of the most useful things that
Jung did I think was to work on this
idea of the integration of the Shadow
because he was really interested in the
idea of evil right especially working
with trying to parcel out what happened
in Nazi Germany and during the second
world war what do you do with the part
of you that's aggressive and and
potentially malevolent you just crush it
that's the super ego response in some
sense do you just put it behind you so
to speak
is that a possibility or do you admit to
its existence and bring it into the game
and that's
see for for Freud in some sense morality
was super ego clamping down on the ID
and they were fundamentally opposed
both Jung and Piaget had a different
idea and I think they were right it's
like no no you invite the bad guys out
to play and so you're an aggressive
hockey player but it's disciplined
aggression that makes you gives you
access to a whole source of energy you
wouldn't otherwise have and then with
regards to sexuality it's like well
untrammeled promiscuity doesn't
constitute a virtue but neither does
unavoidable virginity right in fact I
think that's worse because it also masks
itself with virtue it's like well you
should be able to
you should be able to do things that you
wouldn't do that's the that's like the
definition of a genuinely moral person
they could do it
but they don't
and then that's not cowardice and so
that's you burn off the things that get
in the way of that integration
So when you say dissolve and integrate
might be a good way to sort of bring the
two ideas together that the burning off
and the difficult processes
necessary because the elements of
yourself are structured together in a
rigid way that is not working properly
and that yeah that's what happens to
Geppetto in the belly of the whale he's
so caught in his presuppositions that he
can't escape right and so Pinocchio
represents the new Force so it's very
interesting so when you watch Pinocchio
try to rescue him the first thing
Geppetto does is confuse Pinocchio with
a fish because he wants something to eat
but Pinocchio is better than something
to eat because he can rescue him so he
doesn't need to eat and then Pinocchio
wants to make a fire in Geppetto objects
because he's going to burn up all the
furniture it's like we don't need the
damn Furniture if we're getting out of
the whale you know and so so Geppetto
and he's old so that that that's the
that's the rigid structure that's the
old year that has to die off before the
new year can be born it's a forest fire
that allows for New Growth and that's
how those things are are put together
and see and it's useful to know too
because if you burn something off you
might think well there's nothing left
it's like that's not true if it's dead
Deadwood then you have room for New
Growth and you want to be doing that on
a fairly regular basis that's the that's
that's the snake that sheds its skin and
transforms itself right that's that's
the death and Resurrection from a
psychological perspective it's exactly
the same idea now we don't know the
upper limit to that right because we
don't know what a person would be like
if they let everything that they could
let go let go and only let in what was
seemly let's say
but you can see that it's funny we don't
know that to some degree you can see
people very
you can see people start to do that
without
that's not an
rare experience and
people improve very rapidly it can
improve their lives very rapidly a lot
of it's low-hanging fruit like if you
just stop doing really stupid things
that you know are stupid your life
improves a lot
so and it frees you up it also means
there's a there's an element there
that's also associated with pride
because people tend to take pride in who
they are and that's a bad idea because
that stops you from becoming who you
could be because if you're proud of who
you are you won't let that go when it's
necessary you won't step away from it
you know and then you end up being your
own parody something like that that's
also a very bad idea you want to be
continually stepping away from your
previous self
and so big and I guess part of that too
is that you you have to decide you know
are you
are you order are you chaos are you the
process that mediates between them and
if you're the process that mediates
between them you you are the thing that
transforms
and that's the right attitude for a
human being because that's what we are
we're the thing that voluntarily
confronts chaos and transforms that's
what we are
and so for better or worse you know
that's our deepest biological essence
you might say and so you can let things
go if you know that there's more growth
to come is there a advice you can give
uh now that we know the frame to give to
me Lex about how to uh do this podcast
better how to
think
about this world how to be a good
engineer
how to uh be a good human being
from take your preoccupation with
suffering seriously
it's a serious business
right and that's part of that to Circle
back to the beginning let's say
that's that willingness to gaze into the
abyss which is obviously what you were
doing when you went to Ukraine
it's like
it's gazing into the abyss that makes
you better
the thing is and this is maybe where
Nietzsche's ideas not as differentiated
as it became
sometimes your gaze can be forcefully
directed towards the abyss
and then you're traumatized if it's
involuntary and accidental it can kill
you
the more it's voluntary
the more transformative it is and that's
part of that idea about facing death and
Hell
it's like can you tolerate death and
hell and the answer is this terrible
answer is
yes
to the degree that you're willing to do
it
voluntarily and then you might ask well
why should I have to subject myself to
death and hell I'm innocent
and then the answer to that is
even the innocent must be voluntarily
sacrificed to the highest good
that's such an interesting distinction
voluntary voluntary yeah yeah well
that's why the Central Christian
doctrine is pick up your cross and
follow me
and I'm speaking not in religious terms
saying that I'm just speaking as a
psychologist it's like one of the things
we've learned in the last hundred years
is
voluntary exposure to that which freezes
and terrifies you in measured
proportions is Curative one of the
things I did learn perhaps from looking
into the abyss to the degree that I have
had to or was willing to
was that at some level you have to make
a fundamental statement of faith when
God creates the world after each day he
says he saw that it was good you think
well is it good it's like well there's a
tough question you know do you want to
bring a child into a world such as this
which is a fundamental question of
whether or not it's good
it's an Act of Faith to declare that
it's good
because the evidence is ambivalent
and so then you think okay well
am I going to act as if it's good
and what would happen if I did
and maybe the answer to that is
I think this is the answer
the more you act
out the proposition that it's good
the better it gets
and so that's Dostoevsky said this is
something else
every man is not only responsible for
everything he does but for everything
everyone else does
it's like
what is that profound or are you just
insane
but then you think
is what you received back proportionate
to what you deliver
and the answer to that might be yes
that's a terrifying idea man and it
certainly you can see that it's true in
some sense because people certainly
respond to you
in kind with how you treat them that's
certainly the case I mean it's a it's
terrifying and it's exciting yeah right
that's an adventure isn't it you uh uh
yeah
you create the world's by the way you
live it the the world you experience is
defined by the way you live that world
that's really that's really interesting
and then taken as a collective we create
the world together in that way yeah what
do you think is the meaning of it all
what's the meaning of life Jordan
Peterson you've we've defined it many
many times throughout this conversation
the adventure along the Route man
and I would say
where's that adventure to be found
in faith what's the faith
the highest value is love and truth is
it's handmaiden
that's a statement of faith right
because you can't tell
you have to act it out to see if it's if
it's true yeah and so you can't even
find out without and that's so peculiar
you have to make the commitment a priori
yeah it's like a marriage it's the same
thing
it's like well is this the person for me
well that's the wrong question
how do I find out if this is the person
for me
by binding myself to them
well maybe the same thing's true of life
right you bind yourself to it
and the tighter you bind yourself to it
the more you find out what it is
and that's like a radical Embrace and
it's it's a really radical Embrace
that's the crucifix symbol and more than
that because like I said the the full
passion story isn't death it isn't even
unjust death
it isn't even unjust death and the
crucifixion of the innocent which is
really getting pretty bad it's unjust
torturous
innocent death
attendant upon betrayal and tyranny
followed by hell
well that's a hell of a thing to
radically embrace it's like Bring It On
I think a lot of people put truth as the
highest ideal
and
think they can get to that ideal
while living in a place of cynicism and
ultimately escape from life and hiding
from Life afraid of life and it's a is
beautifully put that uh love is the the
highest ideal to reach for and Truth is
it's handmaiden I try I thought about
that for a long time right this
hierarchy of ideal and the thing about
truth that bitter truth let's say that
cynical truth is it can
break the shackles of naivety and
actually
a burnt cynicism is a moral improvement
over a blind naivety
even though one is in some ways positive
but only because it's protected and the
other is bitter and dark but still
better
but you're not done at that point you're
just barely started it's like you're
cynical
you're not cynical enough
it's like how cynical are you are you
I'm an Auschwitz prison guard level of
cynical
because you have to be you have to go
down pretty deep into the weeds before
you find that part of you but you can
find it if you want and then you think
well I want to stop this
well that was the question you posed in
some sense you're obsessed with say what
happened on these Mass scale
catastrophes
in the communist countries it's like
well
millions of people participated
so you could have and maybe you would
have enjoyed it so what part of that is
you and you can find it if you want
it's it's all there the prisoner the
interrogator the Judas
Pontius Pilate
all of it all of it and that's all of it
is inside us yeah and you just have to
look and once you do maybe eventually
you can find the love good does not
become better by being exaggerated but
worse
and a small evil becomes a big one
through being disregarded and repressed
the shadow is very much a part of human
nature and it is only at night that no
Shadows exist Carl Jung the famous
physicist Richard feyman wrote a letter
to one of his students that wanted to
teach his mother about physics the
letter goes like this tell your son to
stop trying to fill your head with signs
for to fill your heart with love is
enough
now some Reflections on Pride from the
book power versus force people who
engage too much in Pride have a low
level of Consciousness in the
Consciousness map of Dr David Hawkins
shown on his book power versus Force the
downside of pride is arrogance and
denial which blocks personal growth and
it is dependent on external
circumstances
thus it is a net negative condition for
any human
besides as Jordan Peterson explained it
blocks personal growth because it makes
you attached to your current image of
yourself which is molded by your past
thanks for watching if you enjoyed the
greeting content in this video you will
love our newsletter where you can get in
your email all the greeting content plus
the latest things that I've been
pondering
subscribe always for free find the link
below in the description